자, 오늘은 씨 아, 진짜 제작
시간이 이게 거의 네, 시간이
넘어가는이 진짜 이거는 님들 보세요.
이거 그냥 님들 친구도 보라 하세요.
진짜 무조건 보세요. 안 보면 인생
손해 봅니다. 제가 이런 말 잘 안
하는데 그냥 진짜 보세요. 자,
일단은 잠재 능력 기본 지식부터
설명드릴게요. 뭐 아시는 분들은
아시겠지만 자, 모든 부위의 잠재
21% 18% 기대값이 같지가
않습니다. 우리가 어떤 부위인가에
따라서 주스텝 퍼센의 확률이
다릅니다. 뭐 다들 아시잖아요. 뭐
자이 없다. 망토랑 뭐 방패, 목걸리
이런 건 자이 없어서 21%를 띄우기
쉽다. 다들 아시죠? 그래서 그 이제
부위가 목걸이, 망토, 귀걸리,
장갑, 방패. 그래서 얘들은 가격을
좀 덜 쳐 줘야 직도 할 만하고.
자, 그리고 이제 적당히 난이도가
있는 부위는 뭐냐? 모자 신발,
하이. 얘네들은 조금 더 확률이
낮습니다. 자, 그리고 가장 개빡센
부위가 어디냐? 전신옥과 상위.
위쪽이 이제 확률이 낮습니다. 여기가
상당히 낮기 때문에 상이랑 전신옷이
좀 띄우기가 빡세요. 근데 요즘은 또
이제 피무 밸류가 높아서 피무 쓰는
직업은 오히려 양각을 봐서 좋을 수도
있긴 합니다. 자, 그리고 이탈
옵션과 정옵션인데 뭐 이거는 이제
본매하시는 분들은 다들 아실 거예요.
자, 첫 번째 옵션은 기본적으로 높은
수치가 떠요. 주스택 9%가 뜨죠.
그리고 이제 두 번째 줄과 세 번째
줄은 기본적으로 6%가 뜹니다. 근데
이제 여기서 두 번째 줄과 세 번째
줄에서 이탈 옵션이 떠요. 9%가
뜨기도 해요. 근데 그게 확률이
얼마다? 10/ 두 번째 줄이 이제
10/이고 자, 그럼 세 번째 줄은
얼마다? 100. 그래서 여러분들이
이제 세 번째 줄에서 9%를 보는게
뒤지게 힘든 확률이다. 0.07%
이지랄을 하는 거다. 어, 보공을
그래서 세 번째 줄에서 보기가
힘듭니다. 보공도 이제 이탈이기
때문에. 자, 그리고 이제 깡스택과이
스태에 대한 이해인데 이거를
여러분들이 대부분 모를 거예요. 뭐
여기는 환산 사이트가 없기 때문에
여러분들이 이걸 직접 계산해야 되는데
어 쉽지 않습니다. 쉽지 않아요. 뭐
이게 엑셀이 있는게 아니면은 구할
수가 없기 때문에 일단 그거를 일단
좀 설명을 드리겠습니다. 일단은 탯이
1만 오른다고 1만 오르지 않아.
왜? 우리가 잠재 능력으로 퍼센트가
있잖아. 주스텝 퍼센트. 그래서
얘네가 이제 주스텝 퍼센트가
높아지면은 덱스를 우리가 1을 찍으면
이게 2.49가 오르는 거죠. 1을
딱 찍었을 때 이제 퍼센트를 받으니까
띡 더 오르는 거야. 자, 그리고
당연하게도이 주스텝 퍼센트는
당연하게도 이거는 올라갈수록 효율이
떨어집니다. 뭐 당연한 겁니다.
우리가 주스텝가 100%에서
110으로 될 때랑 200에서
210%가 될 때 당연히 효율이
감소할 수밖에 없어요. 200%까지
찍으면 뭐 200% 못 찍지만
그리고이 덱스 퍼센가 높아지면 뭐다?
당연히 덱스 1을 찍었을 때 오르는
덱스 수치가 높아지기 때문에 깡덱스의
효율이 올라갑니다. 그러니까 모다
서로 물고 빨고가 돼야 된다.
깡덱스와 덱스 퍼센 요게 이제 서로
시너지가 생기는 거다. 자, 근데
이제 그렇다고 잠재에서 나오는
깡덱스의 효율이 덱스퍼보다는 좋지
않아요. 자, 그래 가지고 이제 또
추가로 설명드릴게 준스텝 퍼센트는
75레벨 이상이면 모두 동일하게
뜹니다. 9% 6% 이렇게 떠요.
근데 이제 보시면 아시겠지만 자,
레벨이 높으면 뭐가 다르다? 이 깡
스탯이 달라요. 레벨이 높은 템일수록
깡탯이 더 높게 뜬다. 그래서 요거는
그냥 아시면 됩니다. 자, 그래서
이제 올스탯 퍼센트인데 올스탯 이게
현재 에이플 플래이에서 상당히
저평가가 많이 돼 있어요. 상당히
저평가가. 자, 이게 뭐냐? 예를
들어 제 기준으로 무기를 이제
끼려면은 힘이 120이 필요합니다.
그러면 우리가 힘을 120까지
찍는다고 하면은 한 114를
찍어야죠. 그러니까 110은
찍어야지. 6%를 받아도. 그럼
6.6이 오를 거 아니야. 그럼 그냥
러프하게 6으로 잡을게요. 우리가
올스탯 6%를 챙기면은 제가 힘을
6을 덜 찍어도 된다는 거예요.
6을. 쉽죠? 요게 이제 사실상이
올스탯 6퍼가 966에 덱스 6이
달려 있는거나 진배 없다. 거의
비슷한 거다. 그래서 이거를 효율을
환산을 돌려보면 어떻게 된다? 약
25.73%의
효율이 나온다는 거예요. 이걸로
인해서. 뭐 여기 매용하고 뭐
염병하고 하면 또 복잡해지는데 뭐
일단 대략적으로 이렇게 나온다는
거야. 그래서 뭐 이게 27%는 안
나오지만 24%와 27% 그 사이
어딘가에 있다는 거야.이 올스탯이
들어가 있으면은. 근데 이제 가격
차이는 그렇게 심하지 않고. 자,
근데 이제 여기서 또 이제 중요한 거
뭐야? 올스탯 이게 이렇게 좋았던
거라고. 근데 그렇다고 여러분들이
올스탯을 무지성으로 사면 안 된다.
자, 왜 그러냐? 이거는 제가 이전
영상에도 여러 번 설명을 드렸지만
부스탯을 요구하는 직업들이 있죠.
방어구에. 뭐 예를 들어 도적이라고
칠게요. 아 뭐 똑같아요. 다이
직업들은이 80레벨 방어구의 부스
총합이 40을 넘으면 안 됩니다.
왜? 내가 피레타 방어구를 끼려면
덱스가 120이 필요하고 리버스
무기를 끼려면 160이 필요하잖아.
그러니까 이거를 끼려면 120이
필요하기 때문에 얘네이 장비가 40을
넘으면 안 된다고. 그럼 무조건
오버가 되는 거야. 50이 된다고
해서 내가 덱스를 110까지 내리면
저 방혹을 못 끼는 거잖아. 그래서
저게 40 이상이 넘으면 안 되는데
이렇게 이제 신발에 덱스가 이미 붙은
상태에서 올스텐 6퍼까지 들어간다.
그걸로 뭐 덱스가 이제 뭐한 8까지
오른다고 치면은 이것만으로 덱스가
20이 나오는 거죠. 그럼 뭐다?
무조건 오버가 될 확률이 너무
높아지는 거야. 그래서 방어구에 있는
올스텝 퍼센트는 좀 애매합니다.
그렇지만이 공용 부위는 뭐야? 공용
부위는 상관없어. 왜? 80제
방어구에 부스탯을 맞추기 위해 뭐
예를 들어 도적이라고 하면
120이지. 그때이 올스 퍼센트를
쓰는 거기 때문에 공용 부위는 덱스
요구치가 없잖아. 그래서 공용부위의
올스텝 퍼센트는 존나 맛있다는 거야.
아시겠죠? 어려운 개념인데 몰라.
그냥 암기해. 제가 이제 어 약간
선생님들의 이제 마음을 알겠다.
모르겠으면 그냥 암기를 하자. 뭐
아무튼 그렇다. 공룡부위에 붙은
올스탯은 좋다는 거야. 자 그래
가지고 이제 가상의 캐릭터를
만들었습니다. 아이고 이것도 하는게
진짜 개지랄이었는데. 자, 이게
뭐냐면은이 캐릭터는 이제 160레벨에
방어구는 이제 966 꼈고요. 상인는
이제 피무 쓰니까 64에 피무 2초.
그리고 하이는 644. 그리고 자투는
뭐 대충 합스텝 46에 뭐 나머지는
뭐 그냥 20작으로 했습니다. 합스탯
20 정도. 그리고 이제 공용 부위는
근데 24에 뭐 홈목은 좀 비싸니까
그냥 21로 했습니다. 어, 그리고
이제 정축은 16으로 두고 뭐 어쩌고
저쩌고 어, 내용 들어가고 예, 뭐
일단 어쩌고 저쩌고 이런 상황을
가정했습니다. 근데 이거를 보시는 분
중에이 정도 스펙을 찍으신 분들은
저는 극소수라고 생각해요. 이게
빡세죠. 근데 이걸 기준으로
잡을게요. 왜? 님들은 그 스펙이
아니어도 아이템을 구매할 때 결국
끝까지 갔을 때 효율이 중요한
거잖아. 엔드 기준으로 효율이
좋냐마냐? 지금 당장 센게 중요한게
아니잖아. 끝까지 가면 다이기는 템이
뭔지가 중요한 거죠. 실제로 가격
형성이 그렇게 됩니다. 거의 준핸드
기준으로 가격이 잡히거든요. 그래서
가격적인 측면으로 일단 잡겠습니다.이
정도면은 거의 준핸드 정도가
나옵니다. 자, 그랬을 때 이제
효율이 요렇게 나와요. 덱스 1%가
덱스 한 3.8 정도 효율이
나오고요. 공격력 1은 덱스 5.2
정도의 효율이 나옵니다. 그니까
덱스가 이것도 여러분들이 엄청
간단하게 생각하면 어 덱스가
140%인데 왜 덱스가 2.4가 사가
아니지라고 생각할 수 있지만 내가
찍는 덱스 1도 덱스 %를 받으면서
이게 덱스 1을 찍을 때 올라가는
수치가 또 높아지기 때문에 뭐 어쩌고
저쩌고 해서 뭐 아무튼 이렇게
됩니다. 어 아무튼 그 공격력은 이제
주스탯 한 5당 1 정도가 나온다.
그리고 올스탯은 이거는 이제 어떻게
계산한 거냐? 이거는 이제 올스탯을
받으면서 우리가 힘을 덜 찍고 그게
덱스로 왔을 때의 상황 오버가 안
된다는 기준으로요 정도 효율이
나온다는 겁니다. 그래 가지고 네오스
이런 상이 있잖아요. 이게 이제
99이죠. 자, 근데 1%가
3.8이잖아. 그러면은 3%면은
얼마야? 11.4잖아. 그럼 이게
99 3점 얼마가 나온다는 거야?
21.16%. 그래서 966보다 좋은
겁니다. 참고로 이런 방어구가.
그리고 아 이거 보마 기준인데 다른
직업 알려 주세요 하는데 똑같습니다.
비슷해요. 크게 차이 나지 않아. 다
볼 순 없으니까 대충 비슷하다고
보시면 됩니다. 자 근데 그래도
나로는 조금 다르니까 나로는 좀 넣어
드릴게요. 자 나로는 그래서 어떻게
되냐? 비슷해요. 이것도 좀 지작
기준. 준지작 기준이고 럭 1%가 럭
3.6 정도 나오고 이렇게 세팅했을
때 공격력일은 럭 5.7이 나오고
올스탯은요 정도 나온다. 공격력이
다른 직업보다 낮아서 공요율이 조금
더 높게 나와요. 기본적으로 표창을
끼더라도 그래도 공격력이 떨어지기
때문에 조금 더 나오고 이게 바이퍼도
마찬가지고. 자, 그리고 이제 요구
부스 수치가 높아요. 도적은 이제
요구 부스탯이 다른 직업에 40이 더
높습니다. 얘는 160을 요구하거든.
리버스의 그 법사랑 궁수는 뭐
120에서 125를 요구하는데 해적도
그렇고 얘는 좀 더 높아서 그만큼
덱스를 더 찍기 때문에 올스탯의
효율이 조금 더 많이 나온다. 자,
그리고 법사는 어떻게 나오냐? 법사
같은 경우는 법사가 제일 복잡한데 뭐
아무튼 얘도 비슷한 스펙인데 뭐
여기서 어차피 비슷하게 나와요. 자,
마력퍼의 효율이 상당히 높다. 어,
이거는 제가 여러분 설명드렸지만
인트퍼는 챙길 수 있는 부위가 상당히
많은데 인트퍼는 챙길 수 있는 부위가
많은데 마력퍼는 무기뿐. 그래서
마력퍼가 효율이 상당히 높습니다.
그리고 깡마력은 효율이 상당히 낮다.
지금 보시면은 인트 1과 마력이 지금
두 배 이상 차이 나는 걸 확인할 수
있죠. 그리고 이제 마력 퍼센트는
진짜 미친 요율을 보여 주는 거를 볼
수 있습니다. 자, 그러면 이제
뭐야? 우리가 이제 스테프랑 완드
마력 주문서가 인트 1에 마력 2을
올려 주잖아. 그래서 무기 주문서
자기 중요하지가 않습니다. 별로
중요하지 않아요. 무기 주문서가
잠재가 높아야 돼. 잠재가 높고
무기가 원래는 공 2식 고르잖아
물리딜러는. 근데 여기는 투구지력이
오히려 무기보다 좋은 거예요. 그니까
여기서 법사는 오히려 방어구
주문서들이 무기 주문서보다 효율이
좋다 이거임. 법사는 오히려 방어구
주문서들이 오히려 무기보다 좋다는
거야. 그러니까 무기가 좋을 필요가
없습니다. 리버스에 개 지랄 연병을
할 이유가 없어. 그냥 잠재가 높은게
장땡이다. 그 돈으로 방어구나 투구
요런 거를 업그레이드 하는게 훨씬
낫다는 거예요. 투구, 전신,
귀걸리, 망토 이쪽을 업그레이드하는게
낫다는 거예요. 자, 그래 가지고
이제 주위들 가이드를 좀 드리면은
일단 장갑부터 장갑이 지금 많이 잘못
형성이 돼 있습니다. 가격이 일단
일반적인 엔드 유저 기준 주스탯이
5.1이 공격력 1이 나와요. 나로는
5.7이 1이 나오고요. 그리고 좀
엔드 스펙으로 들어가면은 제
스펙이거든요. 제가 레벨업을 조금 더
한다는 가정화에 여기 제가 만든
스펙인데 이게 진짜 엄청
고스펙이거든요.이 기준으로 잡았을 때
이제 어떻게 나오냐? 그러니까 이게
잘못된 생각을 많이들 가지고 있어요.
그러니까 유저들이 잘못된 생각을
가진다. 초고 스펙에서 공격력이
깡패일 거 같지만 자 여기는 이제
잠재 능력으로 인해 두 스태퍼가 너무
높아져서 순수 스탯도 효율이 높아.
오히려 팩이 높아질수록이 순수 스탯도
효율이 원래는 내려가야 돼. 레벨업을
하면서 스탯이 계속 올라가기 때문에.
근데 잠재 퍼센트가 너무 높다
보니까이 주스탯이 오히려 지금
보시면은 스펙이 높아진 기준으로 덱가
올라가서 주스탯이 오히려 효율이
올라갑니다. 그러니까 뭔가 호스팩
되면 7당 1 막 이렇게 나와야 될
것 같잖아. 근데 막 럭퍼 높아지고
덱아지면은 오히려 주스택 효율이
올라간다는 거야. 퍼센트가 너무 높아
가지고. 자, 그래 가지고 이렇게
된다. 근데 이제 현실은 근데 뭐다?
현재 장갑 시세는 대부분 오로지
공격력만으로 결정이 된다는 거예요.
그래서이 두 매물을 비교해 볼게요.
지금 올라와 있는 건데 이게 이제
14억이야. 이건 14입니다. 자,
이거는 13 12억이에요. 근데 이제
실제 성능을 비교해 보면은 합스탯
차이가 이제 8이 납니다. 8이
나면은 이거를 공격력으로 환산하면
공격력이 1.54가 나와요. 그러니까
뭐다? 오히려이 저렴한 아르시나가
코든보다 좋다는 거예요. 그래 가지고
여러분들이 이제 장갑을 사실 때 순수
성능만 고려한다면 대파리 일단
생각하지 말고 하시면은 공격력이 조금
더 낮더라도 주스탯이 높은 매물이
효율이 좋다는 거지. 그러니까 대파이
생각해서 그래도 좀 저렴한 걸로 매물
비교해 보고 그래서 그런게 이제
좋다는 거지. 그리고 이제 996도
좋아. 996은 그냥 어떻게 생각하면
되냐면은 996은 그냥 공격력 2로
보시면 편해요. 주스테 3퍼가 공격력
2보다 좋거든요. 근데 그냥 2로
잡아. 그래가지고 996인데 공격력이
1 낮은데 가격이 똑같아. 996에
다른 거 다 똑같은데 공격력이
11이야. 근데 공격력 10랑 가격이
비슷해. 966이랑. 그럼 그건
사시면 돼요. 그건 이제 13 같은
11이기 때문에. 근데 이제 이런 거
이제 스탯 위주로 살 때는 조심해야
될게 뭐다? 오버덱스. 조심해야
된다. 오버부스. 그래서 특히 이제
도적 같은 경우는 이게 좀 문제가 될
수가 있습니다. 자, 그리고 귀걸리
망토 귀걸리 올스탯. 올스탯 사라.
올스탯이 존나 좋다. 부스탯을
요구하는 직업은 올스탯을 써라.
전사는 좀 필요 없긴 해. 전사도
근데 사면 좋긴 해. 전사가 오히려
근데 힘 올스탯 매물이 많아 가지고
나쁘지 않아. 전사도. 그러니까 이게
뭐야? 결국 올스탯이 6%가 달려
있으면 60% 세 장이 들어가고
시작하는 거예요. 사실상 60% 세
장이 이미 발린 거라고. 근데 이게
가격이 그렇다고 비싸냐? 아니라고.
올스테퍼라고 지금 가격 안 비쌉니다.
똑같아요. 깨워야 5% 비싸요.
5%에서 10% 제가 계속 말하지만
공룡 부위는 뭐다? 스탯 오버도 안
난다. 여러분들이 진짜 뭐 60급자투
뭐 혼에도 혼 그런 말도 안 되는
짓거리를 하는게 아니라면은 절대 안
나요. 안 납니다. 웬만하면 안
나요. 공용 부위는 방어구에서 오버가
나는 거지. 그래 가지고 올스탯은
좋다. 근데 이제 여기서 여러분들이
좀 아셔야 되는게 이런 996
올스탯을 하시면은 뭐 예를 들어
망토라고 치면은 힘을 바르면 안
돼요. 궁수 기준으로 보면은 주문서를
힘을 바르면 안 돼요. 덱스를 발라야
돼. 올스탯을 이렇게 공용 부위에 다
챙기다 보면은 오버가 날 수도 있긴
해. 웬만하면 안 나는데. 근데
만약에 오버가 난다면 그 이유는
여러분들이 망토에 힘을 발라서요.
그냥 덱스 바르세요. 그러시는게
낫습니다. 오버가 날 수 있기
때문에. 자, 그다음에 이제 방어구는
뭐다? 요런 거 사라. 요런게 싸.
쌉니다. 99의 깡임 이런 거.
96의 럭십. 요런 거 사라는 거야.
966인데 올스탯, 96의 힘십
요런게 이제 가성비가 상당히 좋다는
거죠. 근데 이제 문제가 뭐다?
주스탯 대신 부스탯이 붙는 경우는
오버스탯을 여러분들이 잘 계산해야
된다요. 특히 도적. 도적은 그래서
좀 빡세긴 해. 도적은 진짜이
방어구에서 오버덱이 정말 쉽게 나와
가지고. 자, 그래 가지고 근데
여기서 여러분들이 좀 아시면 또
좋은게 뭐냐? 이게 근데 엔드
기준으로는 오버가 많이 나거든요.
근데 여러분들은 그 정도 아니잖아요.
그 정도인 사람들이이 영상 애초에 안
보고 있어. 그냥 다 그냥 966으로
도배하고 있다고. 996에 님들은 그
정도로 안 맞출 거잖아요. 어차피
지작 안 낄 거잖아. 뭐 합스테
30짜리 피라테 낄 거야. 그냥 20
24 이런 거 낄 거잖아. 그러니까
그런 사람들은 뭐다? 어차피 그러면
방어구에 스탯이 낮기 때문에 올스탯이
존나 맛있습니다. 여러분들은 그냥
맛있게 먹을 수 있는 거예요.
올스탯을 오히려 중저자본이 그래서
오히려 올스탯 퍼센가 방어구에 달려
있을 때 맛있다는 거야. 공용
올스탯은 중저자본, 고자본 모두
맛있다. 근데 방어구 올스탯 퍼센트는
중저자본이 훨씬 맛있게 먹는다. 자,
그리고 이제 절대로 부스탯을
계산하라. 이거는 제가 진짜 오늘도
계속 말하고 제가 자투 영상에서도
말하고 법사 드래곤 영상이나 뭐 그냥
매번 말씀하지만 근데 이래도 여러분들
님들은 안 하겠죠. 근데 메이플
플랜이 90% 이상의 유저가 다
오버스탯 지금 찍히고 있습니다. 진짜
너무 많아요. 방송인들도 많아요. 안
나는 사람들이 없어요. 진짜 이거
계산 진짜 잘해야 돼요. 아, 왜
애라 모르겠다 하고 하셔도 되는데
진짜 좀 계산 잘 하셔야 됩니다.
그래서 부스탯이 오버가 많이 날 수
있으니까 진짜 조심해야 됩니다. 이거
진짜 계산을 하셔야 돼요. 특히
도적은 안 나시는 분들이 진짜
적어요. 제가 좀 생각을 많이 해
봐야 돼요. 그니까 어쩔 수 없이
나는 거는 어쩔 수 없는 거긴 해.
무슨 일부러 낮출 필요는 없긴 해.
일부러 무슨 뭐 덱스 낮은 매물을
같은 가격에 살 이유는 없긴 한데
일단 뭐 좀 살 때 좀 고민을 하라는
거지. 그래서 어 오버가 심하면은
자투로 돌리고 자툰 공용부위라 상관이
없으니까 댕덱스 요구치가 없으니까
공용 부위는 근데 상관없다. 그리고
공용 부위에 뭐다? 주스탯
주문서작해라. 부스탯 찍지 말고
그러면은 공룡 부위는 진짜 오버가 안
난다. 내용은 일단 신경 쓰지
마세요. 거기까지 계산해도 그래도
올스테퍼는 무조건 좋으니까. 예 뭐
매용 기준으로 템기긴 해야지. 어,
AP 초기할 때 그렇게 해 봐요.
자, 그래 가지고 지금 그냥 예시를
몇 개를 딱 알려 드릴게요. 자,
대파리를 가정하지 않고 순수 가성비만
생각하는 경우 럭 11이 이제 럭
3% 정도가 나옵니다. 제 앞에서
설명드렸죠? 그러니까 이런 매물이
있어요. 이런 매물이 있다고 하면은
자, 이게 지금 핫스탯 24에 9
6에 럭 10이거든. 근데 이게 지금
6,800만이에요. 근데 이거를
비슷한 급을 들어가려면은 1.8억이
넘어가요. 그니까 이것도 그냥 럭
낮은 거거든. 그니까 이게 사실상
23%에 963이랑 똑같은 건데
그니까 18짜리인데 비슷한게 이제
살려면 1.8억은 들어가야 된다는
거야. 그러니까 이게 엄청난 가성비
매물이라는 거지. 그래서 요런게 이제
다 맛있다는 거예요. 제가 이제 다
찾아본 건데 방금 요런 것도 이제
내가 완전 중저자본이면은 요런 것도
이제 에픽 다리가 괜찮다는 거야.
66에 올스테 4 1700만 이런게
이제 완전 여러분들이 중저다 보니면
이런게 진짜 맛있는 매물입니다.이
진짜 이게 개 맛있는 거야. 이런
게. 그래서 뭐 이제 투구 같은 것도
966상 이게 9에 올스탯 6퍼 붙은
거 뭐 이런 것도 나쁘지 않다는
거죠. 그리고 이제 장갑 같은 것도
예를 들어 장갑도 공 장갑이 이제 막
8천만 이러거든. 근데 이제 7천만에
이렇게 합스탯이 18 높죠. 그니까
이게 웬만한 공식 장갑을 따거든요.
요런 것도 이제 괜찮다는 거죠.
그래서 이런 것도 이제 가성비쪽으로
엄청 괜찮다는 거지. 그리고
여러분들이 이제 엄청 좀 이제
중고자본이다. 그런 분들도 96보다
요런 거 사면은 성능이 어차피
966이랑 똑같이 나와요. 오히려
좋거든요. 지금 오히려 이게 96보다
좋거든. 근데 이게 가격보다 성능은
966보다 100제는 우위. 그
80제는 한 1손에 근데 가격은 한
-40% 말이 안 돼. 너무 저렴해.
근데 물론 이게 이탈 매물이라 많지
않은데 근데 이게 엄청나 이게
가격적으로 너무 좋은 거지. 말일도
안 되는 가성비를 보여요. 그리고
이제 공용 부위도 여러분들이 올스탯이
이제 있으면은 좀 맛있다는 거지.
그래서 요런게 이제 그리고 이제
장갑도 이제 뭐다? 스탯 높은 거
요런게 맛있다는 거예요. 그래서 모두
현재 실제 성능에 비해 가격이
30에서 40% 이상 저렴하게 형성된
경우가 대부분이다. 그래서 여러분들이
이제 템을 살 때 요런 거를 좀 잘
생각을 해서 구매를 하시면은 좀
좋다는 겁니다. 어, 특히 공용
올스텔 이게 진짜 맛이 있다. 그리고
장갑. 장갑이 진짜 잘못됐어. 그니까
다른 거는 뭐 그렇다 치는데 지금
제일 잘못된게 뭐냐면은 지금 현재
메이플 플래닛 가장 잘못 시세가
형성된 부위 장갑이 새끼가 진짜
정상이 아님 얘는 진짜 정상이
아니에요. 지금 형성된 가격이 이게
진짜 세상이 세상이 거꾸로 돌아감
진짜 말도 안 되는 장갑이 공격력만
높고 스탯 좆도 낮은데 막 20억에
팔리고 오히려 개꿀매물이 하루 이틀
동안 안 팔림. 그래서 여러분들이
장갑의 공격력만 너무 집착하지 마라.